tardes es un hecho sin precedentes
extraordinario que complica aún más la
situación política y ahonda en la crisis
de credibilidad y de autoridad de boris
johnson el último primer ministro
investigado por la policía fue tony
blair en el 2007 es un hecho de altísima
gravedad ya que la policía lo que quiere
establecer es si el primer ministro
británico rompió o no las leyes del
confinamiento que él mismo creó con
varias fiestas que se habrían realizado
en el complejo de oficinas de da un
instruido otras entidades del gobierno
como mencionas por ahora johnson cuenta
con el apoyo de su partido el partido de
conservador y por eso pese al escándalo
se mantiene en su cargo sin embargo éste
está
premeditado al resultado de una
investigación que adelanta una
funcionaria del servicio civil británico
que establecerá y que investiga más de
14 fiestas que se habrían realizado de
manera ilegal en el confinamiento en el
2020 si el resultado de esta
investigación no convence a los
copartidarios de johnson entonces
probablemente veremos una moción de
censura que podría terminar con que el
periodo de johnson en downing street ha
terminado sin embargo como les digo éste
está sujeto a esta investigación que se
prevé puede ser publicado esta semana
pero lo cierto es que a estas alturas no
hay certeza porque el anuncio de la
policía hoy cambia completamente el
panorama